what I want to do in this video is do a
quick proof that the that if we take a
rational number and we multiply it times
an irrational number times an irrational
number that this is going to give us
that that's going to give us an
irrational number in irrational number
and I encourage you to actually pause
the video and try to think if you can
prove this on your own and I'll give you
a hint you can prove it by a proof
through contradiction assume that
irrational times an irrational get to a
rational number and then see by
manipulating it whether you can
establish that all of a sudden this
arash this irrational number must
somehow be rational so I'm assuming
you've given a go at it so let's think
about it a little bit I said we will do
it through proof by contradiction so
let's just assume let's assume assume
that a rational a rational x and
irrational times an irrational gives us
a rational number gives us a rational
number so let's say that this so lets to
represent this rational right over here
let's represent it is the ratio of two
integers a over B and then this
irrational number I'll just call that X
so we're saying a over B times X can get
us some rational numbers so let's call
that M over N let's call this equaling M
over N so I'm assuming that a rational a
rational number which can be expressed
as a ratio of two integers times an
irrational number can get me another
rational number so let's see if we can
set up a some form of contradiction here
let's solve for the irrational number
the best way to solve is to multiply
both sides times the reciprocal of this
number right over here so this let's
multiply times B over a times B over a
times B over a and what are we left with
we get our irrational number X we get
our irrational number X being equal to M
times B or we could just write that as
mb mb over n
a over n over n a so why is this
interesting well M is an integer B is an
integer so this whole numerator is an
integer and then this whole denominator
is some integer so I've just right over
here I have a ratio of two integers so
I've just expressed what we assumed to
be an irrational number I've just
expressed it as the ratio of two
integers so now we have X X must be
rational and that is our contradiction
because we assumed that X is irrational
and so therefore since this assumption
leads to this contradiction leads to
this contradiction right over here leads
to this contradiction we cannot this
assumption must be false it must be that
a rational times an irrational is
irrational a rational times an
irrational is irrational